what's the fastest you've ever made a
feature film
so the fastest I've ever shot a feature
film is in a day
um I made of I've made one two three I
did three one day features and one two
day feature so I was working for a
company I was directing movies for them
and I did about 10 or 11 projects for
this company and their budgets were
typically between like 65 000 down to as
low as 30 25 or 30. and we would
typically shoot these in like five to
eight days so
um they had a filmmaker friend that was
doing these like filmed plays in Atlanta
like basically setting up three cameras
and just shooting the plays and they
would kind of release it as a feature
and I was talking to him one day um and
we were talking about that thing and I'm
looking at it and I'm you know I'm an
editor and I was sitting here thinking
about it and I was like God if we had
the sets real sets like like I could I
could do this and make it like a real
movie like not like a filmed play like
do it with coverage I could I could make
this work and so uh he was like and he
started thinking about it and so like
their big thing was they would get like
you know a uh you know kind of a fallen
like like B actor they would put him in
the movie just like those like Bruce
Willis things where he's in the movie
for like five minutes and it's like
starring Bruce Willis so like they were
doing that kind of thing and but they
were like gosh though if we did this in
like one day we can just meet this
person's day right and they can be in
the entire movie they could really
legitimately start in it and we can get
a few of them so they're like yeah we're
gonna cast like this person this person
this person we're gonna do it in a day
so I would uh basically we would run
these things we would do them on sound
stages so like sets and there would need
to be like all the company moves would
need to be within that Sound Stage so
you know like like Cafe they have a cafe
they have a bar they have an apartment
okay it's got to be in a cafe a bar and
apartment so then you know we would set
up the three cameras and you know I
would do you know kind of a basic wide
shot
um I do a
you know like a maybe uh like two over
here and maybe uh maybe three people
over on here one piece of cover three
pieces of coverage run run the scene so
and then we we do the scene once or
twice you know until we get all the way
through it you know and then move the
cameras and you know like start punching
in on people and do this may on an on
average uh two times per scene so you'd
have six pieces of coverage for every
scene you know sometimes more depending
on how shorter long the scene was and
you know like on that second one you
know I'd have good operators and you
know like they would be fishing
close-ups and then you know in between
takes they'd be popping inserts and and
we did it we shot at like 85 pages in a
day and just just knocked them out and
we did there was one month with those
with that company where I shot four
movies like in a month we did a five day
um two one days and a two day and just
bam and then and then you know I'd have
three or four weeks to edit them
so does the talent know that they're
getting their day rate but then they're
like in every scene yeah oh yeah okay
yeah because you know on on indie films
it's almost all about all the
negotiations with Talent are usually
based upon time on set you know so like
now I was not privy to those
negotiations so maybe there were some
bumps because they were all the way
through it I like I don't know I didn't
I wasn't a producer but I I would assume
though that they were pretty much
getting their day rates
how is that on the actor especially for
these you know shooting a feature in one
one day so it can be very hard on the
actors and and the director and the crew
um it takes a very you know and this
isn't just one day features either when
you're making a extremely like low
budget short shoot movie whether it's
one day or five days or ten days there's
specific types of actors that can deal
with that kind of situation and there
are some that can't it's not necessarily
a matter of Talent OR ability some just
can't work under those circumstances so
one of the it wasn't one of the one days
but it was like it was a five day
feature we were working on and one of
the actors uh was a name actor and they
could not handle the the pace and you
know nothing like there it was a very
good talented experienced actor but you
know they kind of broke down halfway
through the first day and like took me
aside and like just tears streaming like
I like I I can't I can't do this I can't
get to where you need to me to go like
they couldn't they just couldn't do it
so they ended up having to you know find
someone else to do that part
um and that's the only time that ever
happened to me but but it's a very
specific like you know type of actor can
do that so like when I'm when I'm
casting uh a movie one of the as a low
budget you know quick schedule movie
like I look at their experience have
they shot other movies like this do they
understand what this set is going to be
like do they understand that this is
going to be like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam you
know that you're only gonna get you know
even on the five day features you know
you're gonna get an average of three
takes two and a half maybe you know it's
it's and some actors can't get there in
three takes you know like they they need
more you know they're they need a longer
rehearsal period or you know like we
even on the one days we do camera
rehearsals but they're they're they're
quick you know so it's not like like
long blocking rehearse or a long camera
rehearsal and if you're in the same
space sometimes the camera rehearsal
will start getting 86 and you're just
you're just rolling through it and they
they they they have to do it so it's
it's there's some people that thrive on
that like I used to describe shooting
features really fast as kind of like
shot clock pool you know it's like you
don't really have time to like line up
and you know agonize over the shot you
just take it you just take take it take
it take it you know and I personally
like I I thrive off of that like I like
that I like the challenge I I wouldn't
I wouldn't shoot a one-day feature again
like like ever you know I did them you
know I'm happy I did it but I I wouldn't
recommend it they're not the best movies
that I ever made but they're better than
you would think you know
um but anyway I like the I do like the
challenge of it
in a situation like that is there a
place for the main actors to go to
collect themselves or they're all in one
space wardrobes here everybody's just
out in the open together yeah no no no
it's like like they would typically
these would typically be like regular
sound stages so you know there'd be
green rooms and holding and you know
that I have been on sets where you know
you know like you're on a practical set
and there basically is no holding I mean
I did I did a talking dog movie once and
you know we had some name talent and you
know they're like okay we have to have
this room set aside for them you know
because you know in their writer or
whatever but I forget what happened but
they like didn't have the room and the
person was like totally cool but here
was this like like person that you'd
seen in all of these movies like growing
up and they're they're sitting there
like on the floor in a corner between
takes but they're but they're totally
down and you know I think that even like
name actors when they're working on
something like that they like they know
what they're getting into you know or
they should and honestly I think like
with that as long as you are
communicative and you don't like promise
something that it's not and you're
really upfront about hey this is what
this is and like this is how it's going
to work and we're gonna do our best to
make you comfortable but you know this
is the situation
most of them will roll with it you know
and and if you get a little you know
pushback or you know like hesitation
go to somebody else
you know sure and sometimes they might
be fine but as you know an extra or or
another smaller actor may want to go and
talk to them yeah and during downtime
and that's kind of their time to
replenish and then they don't really
okay they're always on you know so I
think that could be a problem and I
found you like even in those cases like
those practical locations we still try
to find like even if it's not their
official like you know room we try to
find Space to where they can be or it
doesn't have to be name actors even like
you know the movie I'm getting ready to
do now we have a lead actor and he's
very good and like he needs like like he
needs about he said he needs like two
minutes you know uh before each like new
setup that like he needs to be alone and
not messed with you know and that that's
that's totally a valid process sure you
know it's just sometimes on Independent
like really really indie films you you
have to make some concessions you know
and sometimes like you just you can't
cast that actor you know it's not like
in in this case I'm able to make it work
but you know on another movie maybe
maybe I wouldn't and I would look for
someone that that's why whenever I'm
casting to like an auditions I always
ask people like how do you like to be
directed like how do you like to work
and you can start getting an idea like
hey are we gonna Jive is this person
going to be able to handle the rigors of
you know a twenty thousand dollar you
know five day shoot